this week I don't you heard about this
this week the man wearing a make America
great again hat caused a disruption and
was removed from an international flight
yeah
gets the first time a sitting president
has been kicked off Air Force One
[Applause]
right away dragged away scowling does he
scowl no matter what he does yes
here's a lollipop move President Trump
may be abroad but his ties with Russia
still being investigated it's come out
that President Trump asked to
intelligence chiefs to push back against
the Russian probe yeah
Trump also asked him to make Melania
hold his freakin hand naked or
I love how quick she is when she bats a
hand away
she is fast this is crazy and this is
the crazy thing did you see there's
another another viral video of Melania
Trump again rejecting president Trump's
attempt to hold her hand yep it happened
a second time and yeah
now even Israelis and Palestinians are
saying geez work it out you two it's not
that hard
it can happen Donald Trump's budget
director said people need to stop taking
government money and get a job he then
loudly cleared his throat while glaring
at Ivana Trump so
let's get going please I'm always
freaked that by the giggles the pause
and then a round of applause no idea
what that means
this is crazy scientists have been able
to create baby mice from freeze-dried
Mouse sperm that was kept on the
International Space Station yeah
freeze-dried Mouse yeah when asked about
it the astronaut said wait a minute
so that wasn't ice cream
[Applause]
you know kind of ice cream that would be
nice my sperm Ben and Tom and Jerry's
just got a major award for that Quinn
it's been reported that OJ Simpson could
be released from prison this year yeah
when he heard this Donald Trump said
finally someone to play golf with crazy
story in South Africa follow me on this
a black man received a penis transplant
from a donor who was white friends
described the man as grateful and the
man's girlfriend as disappointed
a new study a new study a new study
found that public pools contain much
more diarrhea than previously thought
so enjoy your Memorial Day weekend
everybody
why am i acting that out that's not good
that's not helping anybody
you